dans une crise dans un incident il ya
toujours une opportunité dans la mesure
où des jardins gère bien cet incident et
couvin continue de prouver à ses membres
qui sont une institution financière
solide à l'écouté de leurs membres qui
s'occupe de la protection des
renseignements la protection d avoir des
jardins vont en sortir grandi
anne sophie le tellier co directrice des
communications chez crypto québec
bonsoir on était en juin dernier à 2
millions 700 mille membres là on est
rendu à 4 millions 200 mille membres
particuliers ce qu'on doit s'inquiéter
de cela c'est plus grave dans la dans la
mesure où il ya plus de personnes
touchées donc en termes de quantité mais
les risques en soi n'est peu plus élevée
la situation n est pas nécessairement
plus graves en matière de risques de
fraude
donc dans le petit que c'est peu plus
élevé parce que l'attention des
consommateurs et qui est à son plus
élevé maintenant tout le monde est très
attentif à ce aussi l'attention des
institutions financières des
institutions politiques
et puis aussi qu'est ce qui arrive c'est
que c'est pas mal moins risqués
peut-être de se faire fraudé son
identité que si on perdait son
portefeuille avec son numéro d'assurance
sociale dans une toile de public dans
les petites classes et ça reste quand
même une aiguille dans une botte de foin
donc c'est que si rien pour se réjouir
mais si c'est encore une fois pour
mitiger le tous les jardins fait bien
ses devoirs j'adore ça reste des
informations y perd sensibles qui ont
été futé on peut pas minimiser ce mais
c'est pas cessé peu une nouvelle gravité
et c'est pas une nouvelle fuite en
monsieur cormier mais aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas une nouvelle fuite c'est la
même fuite mais il ya quand même un
écart d'un million cinq cent mille
j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi un
joueur 10,2 millions 7 et que 4,5
mokhtar on dit finalement 4 millions de
wii donc elle en fait c'est toujours
délicat d'évaluer l'ampleur d'un tué
depuis quand on essaye
de le dire publiquement mais on veut que
ce soit la vraie information et puis la
caisse qui a été notée c'est en fait
qu'il y avait peut-être une lacune au
niveau de la journalisation donc c'est
difficile de dire qui avait accès à
quelles informations camp et que les
informations étaient retirés
c'est sûrement une leçon qu'on pourrait
apprendre de cette situation là qui nous
aident à saisir la gravité de la fuite
plus rapidement donc il ya eu un
manquement potentiellement à ce niveau
là mais il faut dire aussi qu'il ya des
jardins fait preuve de transparence et
puis en ce moment on ne fait ce bond le
de dire qu'il y avait quatre points deux
millions de personnes suite à un rapport
de la police qui nous qui permettait en
fait d'affirmer ça avec quasiment hors
de tout doute mais en même temps on
comprend que desjardins n'était pas
capable de nous dire en juin et n'a pas
été capable durant tout l'été de nous
dire qu'il y avait un million cinq cent
mille personnes qui nous écoutent mais
ce soir qu'ils n'avaient pas qu'ils ne
savaient pas qu'ils que leurs données
avaient été détournés vaut y transporter
ça c'est quelque chose qui peut
s'améliorer justement avec une meilleure
journalisation monde sait ça c'est
qu'est-ce que je pense que la caisse qui
voulait en fait c'est justement de peut
mettre une situation plus grave qu'il ne
l'était réellement mais en même temps là
on ne peut être créé un faux sentiment
de sécurité pour ses membres
alors ça veut dire quoi une meilleure
journalisation qu'est ce qu'on doit
faire justement pour améliorer la
situation
mieux suivre les données mais surtout
mieux les protéger c'est vraiment des
pratiques de sécurité à l'interné puis
bon je sais pas exactement c'est quoi
qui se faisait chez desjardins en ce
sens c'était justement comme dans le
reportage sa a été noté qu'il y avait
des lacunes à ce niveau là donc c'est
vraiment faire des processus à
l'internât en matière de sécurité donc
oui protéger les données mais une partie
aussi la protection des données
c'est de pouvoir journaliser d'avoir des
notes sur qui a accès à quoi quand c'est
quoi les retraits qui ont été faits et
chez terra donc d'avoir des traces de
ceux à même la compagnie et je présume
qu'il faut changer revoir notre pense
notre notre façon de tentes eefje les
personnes le problème fondamental est ce
que c'est la protection ou
d'identification par le numéro
d'assurance sociale par exemple mais en
ce moment du moins c c'est un des
problème fondamental qui ont été
soulevées
travers cette crise là dans l'optique en
ce moment et la réalité c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup d'informations privées des
utilisateurs dont la plus sensible le
numéro d'assurance sociale qui a été
cuite et on ne sait pas elles sont où
et ça ça représente un risque en ce
moment qu'est ce que les gens disaient
un moment donné c'est ok est-ce qu'il
faut remplacer le numéro d'assurance
sociale c'est pas souhaitable qu'on
puisse le remplacer aussi facilement
parce que ça représente un autre ici
c'est facile de remplacer un numéro
d'assurance sociale parce que ça peut se
faire dans le chemin inverse donc qui ça
nous amène vraiment à repenser peut-être
un nouveau mode d'identifier le citoyen
dans une ère numérique donc il ya eu des
modèles justement en scandinavie
notamment en estonie ou qu'il ya une
identité numérique qui est protégé par
des mots de passe des citoyens reste à
voir si c'est une solution qui est
souhaitable au canada au québec
et puis après ça c'est avoir la volonté
politiques mais aussi financières de
pouvoir installer tout ça parce qu'on a
beaucoup d'institutions qui dépendent
sur le numéro d'assurance sociale donc
c'est changer le fonctionnement de tous
ces systèmes l'un et c'est vraiment une
tâche que l'estrade et est-ce que ça
passerait par la chaîne de blocs ou par
un autre type d'authentification est bon
la chaîne de blog ça ça pourrait être
une solution mais ça ne l'est pas
forcément je pense que ça va faire
partie des débats d'après moi
structurantes qui doivent émerger de
cette situation là parce que tout porte
à croire jusqu'à preuve du contraire que
desjardins ne peut de manquements que le
seul liasses
mais comme on le soulève baisse est
important d'utiliser la crise pour dire
c'est quoi le problème de fond est un
des problèmes de fond qui a été soulevée
c'est notre manière de s'authentifier
puis il faut vraiment essayer de penser
à ça avec plusieurs personnes autour de
la table venant du gouvernement mais
aussi des entreprises la société civile
pour penser c'est quoi le
la meilleure méthode pour le 21e siècle
en fait oui parce qu'on est rendus là
effectivement et on voudrait pas que ça
soit produisent de nouveaux anne sophie
le tellier merci beaucoup